glass has now had a full weekend to make
a bunch of money at the box office
hopefully most of you have seen it as
well as my spoiler free review because
this review is going to be nothing but
spoilers that's your warning I'm gonna
get into every detail to plot the ending
all that stuff if you guys saw my
original review you noticed probably
that I didn't grade the film because I
felt conflicted I wasn't sure if I was
on the positive or negative side I was
somewhere on the fence and there was
just things about the movie that that
bugged me and I wanted to see the film
again with fresh eyes with zero
expectations just going in knowing how
it was going to conclude and seeing if I
liked the film any more the second time
when split ended it set up a
confrontation between the beast and
David Dunn who in this film becomes
known as the overseer and that was very
enticing to me and so the first 2025
minutes of this movie gave me just about
everything I wanted I was concerned
though because the beginning of the film
the first act felt like how I imagined
the movie ending and I was like how are
they gonna maintain this because this is
so exciting and this is really well done
and it does take a turn for a more slow
burn film which to me is actually kind
of great because I'm a huge fan of
unbreakable and I love the way that
movie has a slow burn approach to its
characters and how it builds things
slowly and how it lets you breathe and
think and it's just a meditative movie
it really allows you to observe small
moments and I was glad to see glass
bring that back I got no problem with
them being in a psychiatric ward being
treated for what is a perceived illness
in the case of Kevin Wendell crumb
played by James McAvoy obviously he has
di D disassociative identity disorder
but one of those identities is extremely
powerful and can climb on walls and not
get killed by bullets and Ben steel and
this doctor played by Sarah Paulson is
trying to convince all of them that it's
all just a fantasy in their minds
including David who believes that he is
super strong and invovled to a lot of
things like illness but that water is
his primary weakness
Elijah price played by samuel l.jackson
believes that he's a mess
and that he has the opposite side of
what David has and he's the opposite
side of that spectrum I love the idea of
putting these characters in a confined
space and forcing them to be involved in
a mind game that pits them against each
other psychologically this is different
you know this is wacky and weird and
just really out there which is exactly
what I want from an M night Shyamalan
film even films of his that I didn't
appreciate as much as others they all
don't feel like the mainstream they all
feel outside of that it's something I've
always appreciated about his movies and
it's why I've always championed them
he's not a filmmaker concerned with the
trends of the day he wants to be the guy
who's the outlier and glass lives up to
that and I can tell you that on second
viewing I found myself appreciating the
movie a lot more because I was able to
wipe the slate clean anything that I
wanted to see I was able to accept that
I wasn't going to see that and just take
the ride with Shyamalan that being said
the biggest disappointment for me in
this movie was the arc for David Dunn he
doesn't really have won his arc is is
very similar to his in the first
unbreakable and unbreakable he believes
his life to be a certain way someone
comes along and says no your life isn't
like that it's not how you thought
actually you're this and his arc is
eventually accepting that and becoming a
superhero and in this film he believes
himself to be a superhero someone comes
along and says hey no no no you're not a
superhero you're actually this and he
starts to believe that before eventually
accepting that he is a superhero and so
the arc at the very end changes ever so
slightly from the first movie but it
just wasn't very well executed I didn't
really feel that there was enough weight
given to his character he very much felt
like he was on the sidelines he didn't
really have a lot of dialogue there was
a whole like 20 25 minute section in the
middle of where he's not even there when
we see him crying alone once in his cell
and then after that he's kind of gone
for a long time I wish that I had seen
more from him because I loved that
character I do like what they did with
him and his son Spencer treat Clark
returning and giving an excellent
performer
as well not enough people are talking
about how good he is in this movie and I
want to see him in more roles I'm so
happy that he was in the film and how
good he was but there was sort of like a
Batman an Oracle thing going on with
them which I thought was really awesome
naturally James McAvoy is magnificent
and his character definitely carries
some of the more saggy er portions of
the movie there's a few new
personalities this time that come out
some of them speak different languages
there's a great scene where he's
flirting with this orderly loved it
there's a lot of great stuff with him
and as I said he definitely makes the
film feel like it has something going on
when it doesn't necessarily have as much
to do samuel l.jackson barely speaks for
the first hour of the movie in fact I
actually don't think he does speak for
the first hour the movie but once his
character is introduced as being a
presence great stuff I mean there are
scenes throughout that were so so
awesome
I loved him in the wheelchair in the
patient property room and the Beast is
just killing that guy and he's just
sitting there watching really strong
scenes and the meet up between the beast
and mr. glass in that room or he's
trying to convince him to show himself
and that his powers really mean
something perfect couldn't have been
handled better it's really just David's
arc and the twist involving a secret
society of people who try to keep
superheroes from being in the public eye
that I didn't really like that much it's
not the type of twist that ruins the
movie for me especially on second
viewing and seeing Elijah's plan click
into place and this cult that's been
trying to keep superheroes out of the
public eye for all this time kind of
gets there just do but it just felt a
bit unrealistic this idea of them just
being in a restaurant and once enough
people leave the door shuts and now
they're just talking amongst themselves
it just felt like why didn't they just
have like a weird warehouse facility or
something that was definitely private it
just seemed a little unrealistic there
are also some plot hole type things in
the film I discussed it briefly in my
spoiler free review the idea of the
beast being restrained by this strobe
light makes for some great scenes but a
lot of his personalities are very smart
and Denis in particular one of them
should have realized that he could just
cover his eyes and not look at that
light and then kind of you know break
out of the door but that was never
really explored another major issue is
that there is a lot of explaining going
on there's a lot of sequences where
especially the doctor character played
by Paulson just explains things to us
particularly with the twist like she's
looking at one of the orderlies just
saying what Elijah did he went through
the basement because there's more
cameras when she's standing amongst her
fellow cult members she's like I know
what my assignment is and then she says
her assignment and she says why she does
what she does and there's just things
like that where I'm like okay I get it
you're explaining it to us similar to
the twist in the village
another film of his that was very
divisive upon first viewing that more
people have come to like nowadays
I appreciate the village I like how
ballsy and weird it is similar to glass
for instance but he has a habit of
explaining things when they don't really
need to be explained as much and I wish
he would trust audiences just a little
more in that regard it's just really sad
that David goes through everything he
goes through to just be trapped in a
facility for a while and then get
drowned in a mud puddle it's just very
anticlimactic and I wish he had a little
more to do than just reach out touch the
doctors hand realize what's happening
and then he just kind of dies thinking
oh that's over with and it's like he's
the hero you know and he's just kind of
tossed to the side and in a way the film
kind of agrees with the villains because
Elijah's plan the main villain of this
trilogy is what eventually comes to play
and it's viewed as this kind of
beautiful moment because the superhuman
characters are going to be revealed to
the world and now other people can
hopefully come out and say yeah I feel
like I'm one of them too and it's gonna
hopefully start a revolution which is
sort of his idea the problem is it was
treated as a hopeful moment which is
cool but since it's brought about by a
terrorist it feels strange like like I
actually wish
that the film ended on a really sour sad
note instead of making it seem hopeful
like if it if it showed how much chaos
and carnage had to happen for something
else to happen and just got the
execution of that right I love the idea
I love that idea because it isn't safe
it's risky and I fucking love that I
hate safe movies and we had a whole
fucking year of safe shit just now I
love that the ending of this movie is
like whoa that's kind of dark I just
wish that it wasn't treated as a hopeful
moment with all these people holding
hands and the music is swelling but
that's really where my issues end
there's just certain elements of the
execution that could have been a lot
stronger to really boost the feel that M
Night was going for there's a lot of
other things I like - I like the fact
that there are some unbreakable deleted
scenes in here it really adds something
that I've never seen done before the
idea of a movie that was shot almost 20
years ago just having the deleted scenes
incorporated in a sequel because I don't
remember the first deleted scene I
remember the one with young Elijah in
the amusement park but I had forgotten
about the first one and when Bruce
Willis walks through the door for like a
split second I thought to myself holy
shit that is the best d aging CGI I have
ever seen oh it's a deleted scene that's
fucking cool I also like how M Knights
cameo in this film explained a question
I had from split because he has a cameo
and splits and unbreakable unbreakable
he plays the guy who is smuggling drugs
into the stadium and Willis comes and
Pat's him down but then in split he's
like a security guard cameraman watcher
person and so in this one when he plays
that same character he mentions he used
to hang out with some shady folks down
at the stadium I was like okay so it is
the same guy throughout time it's not
just like a weird error between
unbreakable and split and something else
that I feel is left up to interpretation
but could perhaps be explained more in
the future is Casey cook in this film
and what exactly she's doing because M
night makes a real point to show a lot
of close-ups of her hands touching James
McAvoy and
the doctor character even says the power
of true love and affection is something
that you can show these people and I was
like oh shit so are they saying that she
is in some way also special or enhanced
in some way shape or form it just it was
never fully clear and it seems a little
bit open to interpretation but it's
something worth thinking about but
easily the thing that I love recognizing
the most on the second viewing and
something that really stood out to me
was the comic book store scene when
linked to the last thing you see in the
film the comic book store scene where
Casey cook gets a comic by the way
that's the same actor who portrayed the
you better not be jacking off to the
Japanese comics I swear to God
guy in unbreakable same actor that's
really cool
but he mentions how the first issue of
Action Comics had Superman lifting up a
car and how that started it all and at
the end of the film you get that shot of
the beast turning a car and flipping it
over which is you know starting this
origin that hopefully mr. glass wants to
happen of all these superheroes and so
it was just a nice little through line
there that I hope more people can can
notice now this movie is better on the
second viewing and I have to say I'm a
little I'm a little annoyed actually
because Rotten Tomatoes has started to
just take people's reviews and publish
them with a good or bad grade without
actually checking with the person first
that's understandable when I give a
movie a grade like if it's a C+ or below
and they give me a rotten review okay I
get it you did that but I specifically
said in my review for glass that I was
conflicted and I wasn't going to grade
it yet but they still took my review and
threw me in with the the giant mob pile
of rotten reviews I'm actually not gonna
give this film a rotten review I'm going
to give it a positive review I'm gonna
give glass a B I'm not a big fan of the
twist I'm not a big fan of David Dunn's
arc don't like how he went out but
everything else in the film I think is
really different and I like that M night
Shyamalan is making movies like this do
I like everything about this final movie
in the trilogy no am I glad that a
trilogy like this exists fuck yeah
because it's different it's not the same
this isn't another churned out Hollywood
movie M night Shyamalan self-financed
this movie he self-financed split with
the visit he mortgaged his own house to
make that movie so all of the critics
who keep saying things like who's
letting M night Shyamalan make movies
you don't have to have permission to
express yourself through an art form
he's paying for them himself you never
never never never take someone's right
to express themselves through an art
form away just don't do it that's when
we get into the equilibrium world where
art becomes illegal the movie that like
when it came out I was like that makes
no sense
that's a stupid stupid plot but now when
I watch equilibrium I'm like shit I can
actually kind of see that happening
nevertheless glass is a very divisive
movie and in some ways very much so
disappointed me and let me down but on
second viewing especially I found a lot
to like about it and I am glad to see
films like this being made and I will
continue to look forward to films that
Shyamalan makes guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]